combat is a small portion of any
conflict collateral damage the legacy of
destruction in the civilian world is
what conflict accomplishes and I think
in the five years that I covered war
prior to doing this hunt hot zone
project I never realized that because I
was parachuting into places I was
covering you know really what we thought
was important you know the fighting that
was going on and some of the resulting
civilian tragedy but not looking at that
civilian tragedy under the same kind of
prism or with the same kind of
thoughtfulness and and detailed
exploration that we were using on combat
and that creates this sense of you know
war as a game with winners and losers
the fact is you know covering conflict
20 consecutively I began to see the
patterns that emerged and the patterns
were very clear that the combat which
may only last you know a couple of
minutes a couple of hours a couple of
days that short period of time will
create a legacy of destruction for the
civilian population that will go on for
generations you know what we overlooked
in our reporting of war as well is the
root cause of war which is resources any
conflict that you look at anytime in the
world its root cause has been a resource
you know there are elements of religion
and politics that that that actually do
take root during these conflicts and and
they end up being a very prominent
feature within the conflicts but they
all start off with resources I think
that that my my goal in doing this hot
zone project was to make sure that
people learned a little bit more about
what was happening in their world that
they understood you know that there are
a lot of countries a lot of conflicts
going on out there that they know
nothing about and then they should
because the US has involved them in in
some way shape or form
militarily economically or politically I
think an obstacle with both my book and
my documentary and with the hot zone
project overall is that you know it was
looking at you know country after
country and and the legacy of death and
destruction
there's a lot of beautiful things that
are going on beautiful moments within
that tragedy that those those people are
suffering from but sometimes it's hard
to see that and sometimes as a reporter
it's hard to make that clear and as
reporters we have to be very aggressive
and very creative and finding ways to
tell these stories that that bring out
the humanity of what we're covering it
not just the tragedy any one that has
been able to witness the things that
I've witnessed has a responsibility to
share them with the rest of the world
and share their conclusions not
everybody agrees with my conclusions but
I think I I wanted to learn something
from this project I didn't want to just
go on this as some kind of adventure
journalist trying to stay alive you know
that's the wrong reason you know for me
the idea was at the end of this journey
after all these conflict zones is there
going to be some kind of truth that
reveals itself and there was and the
truth is that we emphasize a part of war
that probably is its smallest feature
combat we de-emphasize the part which is
probably its largest feature which is
collateral damage we have to really
reverse those things shift the paradigm
and start looking at war as a legacy of
civil destruction you know not a moment
of a battle
you